because I don't think we're so logical
we're not and I'm an extremely logical
woman I can sit down with you and give
you facts and logic and thought through
ideas but overall I think we are more
emotional women are so self-destructive
my brother is like my mirror I'll do
something and he'll be like why did you
do that do not see how ridiculous that
is and I'm like oh wow yeah and then I
see it in other women as well there
women are so self-absorbed it's actually
phenomenal we don't realize how
self-absorbed we are because we're so up
in our emotions it's like if you feel
something then it's so real and this is
what happens and now the next decision I
make is based on that emotion of feeling
that I felt but doesn't mean that what
happened was real does that make any
sense or is it a little bit too esoteric